cameras have captured exclusive footage
again of dozens of migrants
large group groups with some children
crossing the rio grande
into del rio texas but biden
administration officials
insist the border right there where
those people are just walking across
that's not open that's closed not
kidding watch
the border is closed we are expelling
single adults and families under the
title 42 authority that rests with
the center for disease control we
decided as an administration that we
will not expel
unaccompanied children we knew that here
with reaction the mayor of del rio texas
bruno lozano mayor good morning to you
good morning how are you i'm doing okay
but i'm a little puzzled because the
secretary right there said
the border is closed and yet very
clearly the border is not closed
you're on the other side is the border
closed
i i would very much disagree with that
statement i the way that it's been
handling
or being managed is it seems to be wide
open for unlawful entry in the united
states
okay and you've got a problem because a
lot of those people are coming
into your town uh you've reached out to
the administration for
help and what have they told you
they keep telling us that the borders
under control and i simply do not
understand how with a 393
increase this fiscal year alone last
year we had 19
725 captures at this point and right now
we're at 97
398. i simply do not understand how
that's
under control yeah no kidding mayor do
you remember the old day you've been
down in del rio for a while remember the
old days when the border patrol would be
on one side the american side
of the border and people would be
migrants will be coming over
and they just go hey stop turn around go
home if a border patrol agent said that
these days they'd probably get fired
because the administration
clearly wants people across
it appears that there's a different
approach to immigration
either with lack of personnel to
actually patrol
on the ground and and i just i mean you
see the video 52 persons in that video
that that that was
shown the other day it's it's happening
here in my community
sure you know and the number one
priority
of the bite administration from the
get-go has been coveted
you know trying to get the transmission
rates down and things like that we've
been talking about it every day because
it's a global pandemic
but here's the thing uh as those people
approach the united states
how many of those people uh are actually
being
allowed into the country but are not
being tested for
cova they could be bringing covet in and
that's one of the things you have been
very concerned with
and you've asked the federal government
for help and what have they told
it's you peculiar because americans to
come back into the country from foreign
destinations you have to have a negative
call the 19 tests up to 72 hours
prior your to your flight meanwhile you
have persons entering unlawfully that
have no covet testing
and the department of homeland security
was administering those tests but
they've recently called me dr eastman
recently called me and told me that
dhs can no longer legally administer
those tests and are trying to
collaborate
with the city of del rio so that we can
continue their testing on their behalf
and i think that's absolutely ridiculous
there's obviously no plan of action
and it's being paid for by fema which is
our tax dollars for
natural disaster and i simply do not
understand how
illegal crossing is considered a natural
disaster for human funding
so you know many questions new answers
no kidding and
and mayor it's got to hurt you to say
the administration has no
plan of action because you're a democrat
and this is a democrat president
it's very disturbing that that that
there's continue to be just
extensions of fixes with using band-aids
i mean
you have a bursted pipe in the middle of
your kitchen and it's flooding not only
your house but the entire neighborhood
and it appears that they're just using
duct tape to fix it you got to cut the
source
it's quite simple any plumber would tell
you turn off the water that is such a
good way to put it
mayor the dhs had this statement all
along the southwest border our team has
established partnerships with
community-based organizations
cities and counties to ensure that all
migrants released from dhs custody
are tested and isolated in compliance
with recommendations
we have a system in place to reimburse
100 percent of the cost provided
that either the state or locality
accepts the funding
do you agree with that does that i think
that's i think that's ridiculous i think
that's just
enticing the migrants to come illegally
all over again i mean they're going to
get free testing
meanwhile americans have to pay for that
test when they're in their foreign
destinations so
it just doesn't make any sense why
people who cross unlockly illegally are
getting this
this royal treatment um post-crossing
yeah so you know what um secretary
mayorka should call you because you say
that statement is ridiculous and at the
same time you say that
him saying the border is closed that's
ridiculous as well
you've got a lot of questions but you
have not gotten a lot of answers and
that is the troubling part
mayor thank you very much for joining us
good luck to you thank you again for
having me